this is a production of Cornell
University
so last year I was I left off telling
you guys about our efforts to map large
effect early bite resistant slow sigh
and to tomato breeding programs and I
was telling you how we plan to use this
information to learn more about the
tomato early blight petha system and to
develop new inbreds with enhanced
disease resistance so i showed you that
we found four early by louis i of real
interest here two of which were
predictive predictive of stem lesion
resistance and that's EB 1.1 and eb 9
here colored in green and two were
predictive of resistance to defoliation
and those were EB 1.2 and EB 5 colored
in purple now of these four QTL e b5 and
eb 9 had statistically significant
resistance effects across five breeding
populations over the course of three
years while EB 1.2 was more
inconsistently detected now we've since
used this information to inform a
genome-wide marker-assisted backcross
scheme to rapidly pyramid these early by
KTL into two elite tomato backgrounds
from two separate market classes now the
first of these releases CU 1913 57 is a
northeast adapted medium-sized Fresh
Market slicing tomato and the other CU
2010 41 is a determinant Midwestern
processing type and these tomatoes which
carry additional resistances to a host
of other diseases are being thoroughly
evaluated this summer and are being
released to third-party breeding
programs through the Cornell vegetable
breeding Institute now alongside these
inbred releases we also wanted to
provide reliable and background
independent markers for these early
blight resistant slow sigh and the
traditional way to do this would be to
iteratively find map refining the
confidence intervals until it was
possible to identify and validate
confidence or candidate genes that would
become the target of molecular markers
but this kind of work is really time and
resource intensive especially when it
comes to quantitative disease resistance
and from a practical breeding
perspective
we don't really need to know the causal
variants and I would argue it's good
enough just to find the smallest extant
resistance bearing haplotype or the
smallest introgression from the
ancestral resistance source and then
from there you can design markers that
are specific to that haplotype and these
markers should be capable of predicting
resistance across breeding programs
regardless of the recent ancestry so my
project partner and I are attempting to
do exactly that by sequencing landmark
resistant inbreds from more than 80
years of early blight resistance
breeding and by applying the tools of
population genetics so to do this
successfully our first challenge was to
dig through the available breeding
records and to come up with a
hypothesized ancestral pathway for each
of our resistance QTL and i want to take
you now through one such history which
begins with a tomato reader by the name
of dr. George B Renard now dr. Renard
was an avid birdwatcher and in fact he
served on the board of the Cornell
ornithology lab where he helped them to
build out their recordings of the US and
Caribbean bird songs but in the 1930s
and 1940s dr. Renard worked at the
vegetable breeding laboratory in
Charleston South Carolina now there he
and CF and ruse works out the first
early bite inoculation protocols
allowing them to screen tomato
accessions for genetic resistance and he
and Andrews found resistance in several
Tomatoes but one an English forcing
tomato by the name of Devon surprise is
described in their 1944 publication as
having particularly strong resistance to
early bite stem lesions which is a face
of the disease also known as cholera now
importantly they also observed
inheritance ratios that suggested that
this resistance was was caused by a
single underlying locust now dr. Renard
eventually left the USDA to become a
tomato breeder for Campbell's and the
story might have ended there were it not
for another important and more
well-known early blight resistant tomato
called Campbell's 1943
now this tomato was described in a 1977
publication by Thomas Barksdale as
having excellent early blight Colorado
resistance and Barksdale also writes
that quote Campbell's 1943 was kindly
provided us by dr. George B Bernard of
the Campbell Institute for agricultural
research so this suggests that dr.
Renard having previously discovered
discovered the early bite resistance in
Devon surprised then use this tomato to
create Campbell's 1943 and from this
point forward recreating the pedigree is
much easier because dr. Randy Gardner
now emeritus professor at North Carolina
State University picked up Campbell's
1943 and used this as a source of
resistance for his 1980s release NCE BR
2 which had early bite stem lesion
resistance and then NCE BR 2 was used in
a subsequent 2008 release of NCC eld r1
and then NC CEO BR 1 was used by the
Cornell tomato breeding program as a
source of resistance for Cu 15 1095
which is in turn in the pedigree of our
two newest tomato releases and if we
repeat this process for other sources of
early blight resistance in the pedigree
I was able to put together this greatly
simplified hypothesized pedigree of
early blight resistance in our Tomatoes
that spans some 80 plus years of
breeding now the next step is to obtain
whole genome sequences for all of these
lines now some of these sequences were
available from the NCBI sequence read
archive or from our collaborators at The
Ohio State University and the remaining
nine Tomatoes though we sequenced
ourselves we built libraries using the
next arrow flex protocol and then ran
them on a next sequencer breeds were
then aligned to be Hinds 1706 reference
genome and this is the 4.0 reference
genome and snips were called with the
gatk for pipeline and this yielded about
12 X filtered coverage over the variants
so again if our hypothesized pedigree is
correct for the chromosome 9 QT l eb9
coming from Devon surprise then we
should be able to observe a shared hafla
type near a benign in Devon
surprise and in all of our landmark
early blight resistant inbreds now this
plot which is based on the output of the
a bababa test shows us that this is
indeed the case now
this analysis looks for the evidence of
introgression x' in triplet snip
contrast giving a D statistic that can
be used to paint chromosomes by ancestry
and also to visualize homologous hafla
types and what we find is that in all of
the early blight resistant entries they
share a solid red block of snips near
the ev9 locus and this suggests say
Devon's a shared Devon surprise
introgression in contrast snips that are
more consistent with a high in 1706
ancestry are colored in blue now another
way to find regions of high sequence
similarity is to window the genome and
then to use a clustering algorithm to
intelligently group the resulting alpha
types now here you can see an example
where I've projected 30 tomatoes from
four different clades into a two
dimensional PCA space for a single
genomic window near the eb9 KTL then I
used the k-means algorithm to cluster
the samples and found that it perfectly
separated the early blight resistant and
susceptible large rooted cultivars from
each other from two cherry tomato types
and from the wild species solanum fabric
IDs now this type of unsupervised
clustering analysis is really nice
because it's computationally pretty
trivial and because we can improve our
ability to distinguish among observable
haplotypes as we add additional
sequences to our database now once a
sample in a window is classified as a
member of a group we can then ask if
that sample is in the same or different
group from some putative ancestral line
of interest we can then color the areas
that have the same k-means clustering
nation to visualize homologous
haplotypes and even introgression now
here is one such plot of chromosome 9
inclusive of the 8 resistant samples
that I talked about early
they're blocked by this green resistant
bar at the top and then two random
susceptible samples from the pedigree I
described earlier at the bottom and the
genomic windows were colored if in any
window they were in the same cluster as
Devin surprise and the resistant
tomatoes are also sorted according to
their hypothesized ancestry with Devin
surprise the putative donor followed by
C 1943 and CBR to NCC gob r1 and then
our three most recent Cornell releases
and what's really cool about a plot like
this is you can actually watch the
haplotype from Devin's surprise decay
over time with phenotypic selection
going from a large introgression in
Campbell's 1943 to a relatively small
one into North Carolina tomatoes and
here on the right we've zoomed in to a
95% confidence interval for the eb9
locus the black ticks denote the
confidence interval boundaries and the
most predictive spin marker at the
center and we can clearly see that the
smallest contiguous Devin surprise
haplotype was present in the sample and
ccel be our 1a and this gives us a new
resistance haplotype size that's about
33% smaller than before or about 1.2
megabase pairs and furthermore these
data strongly suggest that our modern
early blight stem resistance traces back
directly to an early 20th century tomato
developed in Devon England which was
then improved by dr. Renard and through
significant public sector breeding
efforts spanning more than 40 years now
I don't really have time today to tell
you the whole story for the other
resistance Llosa here but I did want to
show you that we can do use the same
methods to trace our early blight 5
resistance locust to an unimproved
tamanna breeding lying named Hawaii 7 9
9 8 and in this case we were actually
able to shrink our interval size by more
than 60% over our prior boundaries so
this demonstrates the power of this
approach to reduce QTL confidence
intervals without ever having to do fine
mapping so now that we have some
preliminary success with this project we
want to scale this up to include wild
species and many more modern and
heirloom tomatoes
for which archived sequences already
exist and this should allow us to
further trace the history of our of our
resistance low sigh back to the wild
species donors and also to determine
whether there are other sequence
Tomatoes sitting in the gene bank that
share this early blight resistance
haplotype we aim to identify snips that
are specific to this resistance
haplotype to find excellent candidates
for portable and background independent
molecular markers and finally we hope
that this work will help to reveal
Tomatoes with unique versions of the
resistance haplotypes which could
predict the presence of novel alleles
conferring even stronger early blight
resistance and with that I'd like to
thank in particular Martha said ermine
who's by my project partner on this this
is a this was largely funded from a sips
Schmidt out Novak small Grants Program I
also want to thank from the Mazurek lab
Carla plant and helped us to brainstorm
these methods these methods have these
methods for our project I'd like to
thank everyone in the Mutchler breeding
program and in the francis breeding
program at osu and also my graduate of
committee members and with that i think
i have a couple more minutes here to
take questions stop sharing the screen
you can type if you have questions can
take one minute for one minute for
question running out of time any leads
on the background of devon surprise so
the trail stops there I tried looking up
so I was able to find the company that
sold Devon surprise but they've folded
long ago I don't I can't identify who
the breeder is so I think from this
point forward we're gonna try and find a
wild species that that is that best
supports introgression and Devon
surprise and and make our best claim
that that's the ultimate source in this
resistance let's see like the historic
approach thank you very much do you
think that on reducing the haplotype
sizes for finer mapping you could be
confounding the effects of other
potential causal qtls
do I think that reducing the haplotype
sizes for finer mapping I
I'm sure I totally understand the
question there but I don't think that
where we are confounding the effects I
think we could be leaving out other QTL
and in fact I have already left out
several QTL that were of minor effect
here we really wanted to focus on the
largest QTL of interest large defect QTL
of interest because that's really what
the breeding programs are most
interested in when they're trying to
bring these into their background and
then another question what tool were
using for haplotype visualization so I
used Python for creating the to do the
k-means clustering analysis and then the
these plots are actually based on
they're actually just ggplot bar plots
in which I've stripped out all of the
unnecessary background detail all the
grids and everything and used facet wrap
to stack all of the entries on top of
each other so that we can do comparisons
across entries nice I think that is one
more question do we have markers for key
tl5 and key tl9 that seed companies
could use yes I mean we currently have
markers that we are using in our own
breeding program but really the purpose
for that are the motivating factor for
that all of this work is to define
markers that will be useful for all
backgrounds so yes we currently have
markers that could be used they may not
be polymorphic in all backgrounds but we
hope that by the end of this work they
will be robust enough for any and all
programs to use them okay I think there
are no more questions let's thank Taylor
for your nice work and move on to the
third speaker thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu